welcome back to special report let's  take a quick look at what's happening on  the ground in ukraine bombardment around  kharkiv out here and key of seeing that  as well meantime russian forces are  moving down from the north and the east  trying that encirclement doubling down  as you heard from the cia director but  it hasn't happened yet the biggest story  of the day continues to be  what poland has announced that they want  to move these mig-29s to ramstein in  germany and possibly then move those  planes those jets to keeve us hasn't  figured out exactly how that's going to  happen or if it's going to happen  meantime in the western part of the  country in la vie right here leaders are  struggling with tens of thousands of  refugees really every day trying to flee  ukraine hey sean hannity here hey click  here to subscribe to fox news youtube  page and catch our hottest interviews  and most compelling analysis you will  not get it anywhere else